la población de una ciudad crece con una
tasa de 1.2 t menos 2 de personas por
año donde t es el número de años en t
igual a 2 años la población es de 1500
personas cuánto creció la población
aproximadamente entre t igualados y de
igual a 5 cuál es la población de la
ciudad en el año de igual a 5 una vez
que encontremos la respuesta a la
primera pregunta la respuesta de la
segunda pregunta la encontraremos de una
forma bastante directa una vez que
conozcamos cuánto crece la población
sólo tendremos que agregar lo necesario
para t igual a 5 pausa en el vídeo y
traten de resolverlo por su cuenta lo
importante aquí es darnos cuenta de que
esta parte expresa la tasa o qué tan
rápido crece la población vamos a hacer
un repaso breve sobre la noción de una
curva de tasa de cambio aquí dibujo los
ejes mi eje del tiempo y mi eje de tasa
de cambio esto va a mostrar qué tan
rápido cambia el crecimiento como
función del tiempo si vemos este punto
de aquí en la función no es la cantidad
de personas que existen
en ese momento sino cuál es la tasa de
cambio de la población en ese momento
como hemos visto en vídeos anteriores
si queremos medir el cambio indicado por
esto en este caso el cambio en la
población
tenemos que encontrar el área bajo la
curva entre estos dos momentos que nos
interesan porque tiene sentido esto
imaginen un pequeño cambio en el tiempo
tan pequeño que la tasa de cambio en ese
rango parece constante cuando medimos
este cambio o mejor dicho cuando medimos
la acumulación de dicho cambio
obtendremos la tasa por el cambio de
tiempo o lo que es lo mismo el área de
este rectángulo es el área bajo la curva
en este pequeño rango de tiempo lo que
queremos hacer es encontrar el área bajo
esta curva del intervalo de igualados
igual a 5 ya hemos visto varias veces en
cálculo cómo expresar esto es la
integral definida
dt igualados a está igual a 5 de esta
expresión y a la 1.2 t
menos 2 t dt si evaluamos esto tendremos
la respuesta de la primera pregunta
vamos a calcular lo cual es
andy derivada de la 1.20 vamos a
escribirlo por acá es de 6 puntos de 12
décimas es igual a 6 quintos
dt esta es la integral indefinida pues
solamente quiero encontrar la anti
derivada de esto si aquí escribo 6
quintos puedo aplicar la sustitución o
el método inverso de la regla de la
cadena podemos escribir 6 quintos aquí
si escribiéramos 5 sextos por acá
podemos poner o quitar constantes en una
integral o escalar constantes y si
multiplicamos 6 quintos por 5 sextos nos
da 1 esto va a ser igual a 5 sextos por
lo que tenemos aquí esta anti derivada
es bastante directa si la derivada de
seis quintos porte es esta puedo
encontrar la anti derivada con respecto
a seis quinto sports es esencialmente
aplicamos la sustitución y si esto es
nuestra un esto y esto serán nuestra de
1 tenemos 5 sextos por el a las seis
quintos porte y si tenemos una integral
indefinida tenemos que agregar una
constante aquí pueden
verificar que la derivada de esto es lo
que tenemos aquí es a la 1.2 t
esto es igual a la anti derivada de esta
parte de aquí 5 sextos x
a las 6 quintos p y la anti derivada de
2 t este cuadrada esto lo evaluaremos en
5 y en 2
finalmente calcularemos la diferencia
para evaluar esto cuando te es igual a 5
tenemos 5 sextos por e
a las 6 puntos por 5 nos da a las 6
menos 5 al cuadrado que es 25 a todo
esto le restamos esta misma expresión
evaluada en t igual a 25 sextos por e
a las seis quintos por 2 es 12 quintos o
2.4 menos 2 al cuadrado que es 4 que nos
queda al final podemos asociar estos 5
sextos de aquí y de acá que multiplican
a las 6 menos 2.4 distribuimos este
signo negativo y después tenemos 25
menos 4 negativo que es 4 positivo lo
que nos da menos 21 usamos la
calculadora para saber cuánto nos da
esto
6 nos da aproximadamente 400 3.43 menos
menos 2.4 que es el exponente de el
resultado nos da aproximadamente 392
punto 40 esto es lo que está entre
paréntesis y lo multiplicamos por 5 y lo
dividimos entre 6 nos da esta cantidad a
la que le vamos a restar 21 el resultado
final es aproximadamente 300 6.00 lo
escribimos cuánto creció la población
aproximadamente entre t igualados y de
igual a 5 aproximadamente 306 personas
cuál es la población de la ciudad en el
año t igual a 5 siente igual a 2 había
1.500 personas y durante este intervalo
se incrementó la población en 306
personas el total de la población es de
1806 personas en el año t igual a 5 y
con esto terminamos